ich glaube unser skype ist klar wieder
weg oder ich bin nicht schuldig was so
ich dachte ich müsse jetzt wieder so
improvisieren habe ich nicht nur kohle
ich weiß nicht womit man diese womit
treibt man extrakte an schreibt mal
bitte in die kommentare jahr mit kohle
geht das nicht sieht man wie macht man
wie treibt mit extrakten minecraft
extrakt vor wie mach was machen als mit
video tutorial video tutorial
doch so einfach schien der tooway strip
des sektors energy energy storage
systems as ribery trat nur ganz kurz
abgelenkt weil ich muss das auf skype
gucken soll da bin ich wieder hallo
moment damit hätte berlinerin liebe
[ __ ] also übrigens wenn du wenn du
diese ganzen sachen die ich hier oben
wenn du es aus rein kommst links taste
sind vier gegenstände sind extrakte
generate zuwendet die abbauen will in
der kiste ist eine bronze rang damit
muss einfach noch rechtsklick drauf
machen
deswegen müssen wir das mit dem
generator verbinden
das heißt wie baur trainiert was so
erwarte ich noch dass morgens kurz so
die sachen kann ja weg tun
jetzt machen
ein glas hohlglas last lässt das hosting
glas wo ist dein glas solchen das
aufbauen jetzt hier alles glas wo bist
du mein glas wo bist du glaubst du bist
du ich mach das mal so general electric
fördern wollen noch kupferkabeln
deutlich macht was mit vize pitsch
domain gott krass konkreter krass also
alle jetzt bei mir gucken und bykov
vorbeischauen dieser folge es geht
anscheinend als der weight watchers mal
was ich komme ja oder mach deine sache
ich komme was da ist es richtig krank
hier zeigt mal habe das so verbunden
compaq label geil jetzt muss ich hier
den generator einpacken
ja ich will die kaputten die koppel
da ist jetzt energie guck mal weiter ein
die man hier links rein extractor
dokuments an den generator da geht die
kohle nämlich grad runter weil der
treibt den extractor an und dieser macht
nun recipes und da rauskommt wenn dabei
rauskommt dann bin ich ein talent dann
kommt ihr alle zu mir gebt mir daumen
hoch als belohnung
da kommt direkt aus echtem soll talent
alter wir brauchen wir richtig viel
kohle dazu nein ganz recht ganz links
das links so habe ich rauskomme macht
elektriker aus holz robert du musst
warten guckt dann kommt der gleichen
rabatte gucke geil hab ich genau hier
kommt guck mal hier kommt tropenholz
raus wenn ich in electric fällen etwas
rein packe rechts da kommt tropenholz
raus das kann auch so umwandeln ach was
kommt heraus wenn ich hier so was ist
das andere rapper wird was ich auch dir
angetan habe ich nicht das normale doch
in die habe ich tropenholz brauchen wir
allerdings für die hier gar nichts raus
egal
bis warschau wieder so wird es auf jeden
fall schon mal cool das also was ist das
da so sachen rauskommen will ich sehr
cool freut mich
wir müssen allerdings sortieren erste
liga zu kicken
stimmt
sollten wir machen so sind gleich so dr
ich bin dabei und lässt alles aufzubauen
um die kisten zu sortieren hast du glas
ich brauche glas
glas unlimited lassen ja ich brauche
glas haben bin ich da sind glasscheiben
die sagen wir so viele glasscheiben auf
die fenster mitgemacht dann verbrannt
das ist später fertig ist meinem leben
aber ich hab dir hier kohle rein getan
in den links dann packt er noch einfach
sand drauf in den linken offen
wir sind jetzt ein kuschelig dir sogar
noch die sachen bräuchte jetzt raus und
für diese spinne die nervt sie psychisch
plaza de las es die hatte nichts getan
doch sie nervt das ist ja okay natürlich
aber die anderen cops oder lass uns
einfach pennen gehn und verschwindet die
vielleicht ja gut ich gehe mal ganz kurz
runter soll so leute jetzt haben auch
die ganzen stimulation faktoren die die
ganze zeit meine batterie war beim start
zu bekommen
wir haben jetzt nicht was mit vize bees
gemacht so ist das bringt müssen wir
auch vernünftige dings mal ein baum
künftige wende nehmen was mache ich
eigentlich nicht weil ich gar nicht
gesehen hatten kurt machen
jetzt ist das ganz normal im stonewall
ball ins tor
wir machen das auch wieder aus hier die
wende
aber ach so ja ich weiß deutschland
stehe aus welchem aus welchem material
ich würde sagen da ist schon so viel
eher scheint das aus diesem ding was
worauf die decke ist aus marmor
das könnte aber die wende aus stein oder
ode an die als zwar wäre diese kameras
der duft der die decke aus marmor weg
ist eigentlich die decke hier ja die
decke und der boden auch das marmor
guck mal hier ich hab stein für dich hat
er hier nicht um die ecke und links mit
abgehauen ist ok dass wir sitzen das sie
sitzen das ist es jedoch zwei scheiben
zwei glas und habe ich alles habe ich
die mal mehr war aber auch stein ziel 29
22 euro unterbringen
hier ist absperrung damit man darunter
fallen kann abgesehen es gut gemacht
oder es gut gemacht oder weiß nicht ob
ich mache die wände aus diesem stein
zieht werde sehen wie cool ich möchte
den boni und dem glas als besonderer
machen was mama okay ich mache das
erstmal bis hierhin
die bringt nichts oder keine ahnung
womit sie sind schön aus wasser ich hab
kein wasser wir haben draußen den in dem
dings oder machst glas kaputt
er verbrennt der da erst mal richtige
motto bist du ja ich hab gedacht ich
mache diesen weg dann kann ich etwas
normales ist keine gute idee gewesen
ich muss erst mal daneben weg machen
also die reihenfolge war wissen und
unlogisch rette mich sollte ich ihn
retten pusten oder was jetzt erst mal
auf einer solchen stelle
was ich mach das mal wie solchen das
hier machen super retten schön boden was
weiß wissen wie machen ich glaube ich
mache das was dem boden neben werden
dafür aber schon zwei mal noch scheißen
track soll man hier rumlaufen können
simon simon zeigt die wand hierhin
ziehen warte hier herumlaufen können ihr
so wollt euch die hinziehen sag mal hier
solange man die wäsche noch größer durch
oder ja wo soll ich die wand ein
herzchen hier so ich weiß es nicht ich
weiß es einfach nicht
ich habe keine ahnung bekommt dürfte ich
habe die idee lass mich mal machen
machte weil aber habe ich gut bis
abwechselte jetzt vor jeder der arbeitet
muss ist ein bisschen anders machen die
zuschauer nicht auf dasselbe was anderes
macht dann kümmert sich darum dass wir
noch mehr eisen kriegen uns aber da
ersten staffel gehen kann
du kannst noch ganz gut helfen dass hier
ausgraben
okay man einfach in die richtung dahin
ich komme später getroffen
vorbereitet wie ein gott ja ich hab kein
eisen aber eine in einer kiste sind drei
reisen ich war es eine katze oder vier
nehmen ja so viel macht ist ich glaube
ich bin ich schon fertig wenn du kommst
hier nicht doch da den saphir euch noch
steckte ich komme gibt es motto wenn ich
komme
es steht überall gibt es die meisten
störe ich habe ihnen so was grenzen ist
gefunden müssen dass das gesetz der
charts blieb bei unserem haus als ob
ehrlich nein danke dass du jetzt für die
letzten blöcke gekommen simon die show
werde ich mich nützlich machen oder
etwas anschaut danke für deine
glorreiche hilfe bitte gerne danke so
geht das jetzt so wenn ich das hier so
mache nachts geht es reicht auch
erstmals da geht's nicht